Vielen Dank für die Kommentare
unter dem Video.
Es freut mich sehr,
dass es so viele sind,
und dass diese Repo
bei euch etwas ausgelöst hat.
Für diesen Film
schnappte ich meine Kamera,
ging raus und sprach mit Singles.
Ich hoffte darauf,
dass sie mir etwas preisgeben.
Und es hat wohl funktioniert.
Einige können sich mit den
Protagonistinnen identifizieren.
Caro Eule sagt z.B.:
"Mir geht's gleich
wie Nina und Isabelle,
ich habe einfach keinen Bock
auf Online-Dating."
Nach diesem Film muss ich sagen:
Das verstehe ich.
Es ist ziemlich kompliziert
momentan.
Menina schreibt: "Es braucht
unbedingt mehr solche Beiträge!"
"Es gibt mir ein gutes Gefühl,
da nicht alleine zu sein."
Andere schreiben auch, dass sie
während der Pandemie ihre Traumfrau
oder ihren Traummann kennenlernten.
So schreibt z.B. Aniko:
Scheinbar schon,
das freut mich wirklich.
Es gibt auch Menschen,
die ganz normal weiter daten
oder sich den Massnahmen
angepasst haben.
Bino501 schreibt z.B.:
Das finde ich vernünftig.
Ein anderes Thema,
das in den Kommentaren oft aufkam:
Soll man Menschen
während der Pandemie
zu sich nach Hause holen oder nicht?
Weil man momentan keine anderen
Möglichkeiten hat für Treffen.
Zur Geschichte von Nina, die ja auch
Menschen zu sich nach Hause einlud,
sagte naitomea14:
"Sorry, ich bin ja auch eine Frau,
aber ich würde nie einen Wildfremden
von Tinder einladen."
"Du weisst ja nicht,
wen du dir da angelacht hast."
"Und ich würde auch nicht
zu einem Wildfremden nach Hause."
Sicherheit beim Daten – dieses Thema
ist mir bei der Recherche
zu diesem Film oft begegnet.
Viele erzählten mir,
dass es nur zwei Möglichkeiten gab:
sich draussen treffen – darauf
hat man bei 5 °C halt keine Lust –
oder bei sich zu Hause -
und das bringt auch Risiken mit sich.
Nina erzählte mir das auch – deshalb
skype ich jetzt nochmals mit ihr.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Ich nehme an, du kennst das:
Bevor man ein Date hat,
den Standort teilen, seinen
Freundinnen sagen, wen man trifft.
Wie machst du das?
Etwa so, wie du es gesagt hast.
Leider.
Wenn ich ein Date habe mit jemandem,
den ich besser kenne,
ist es anders als bei Fremden.
Man kennt die Absichten ja nicht.
Im Internet
kann man ja alles erzählen.
Man kann sich Zeit nehmen,
um eine Antwort zu schreiben
oder ein anderes Foto nehmen.
Oder ein Foto ohne Gesicht.
Wenn jemand auf Tinder sein Gesicht
nie zeigt auf einem Foto,
ist das schon eher suspekt.
Wem gibst du Bescheid vor einem
Date, wenn jemand zu dir kommt?
Das ist unterschiedlich. Wenn meine
Nachbarin da ist, sage ich es ihr.
Das ist klug. Sie hört dich
wahrscheinlich, wenn etwas ist.
Genau. Letztes Mal wusste es
noch eine Freundin und mein Bruder.
Ich sagte: "Wenn ich mich
bis morgen Mittag nicht melde,
ist etwas nicht gut."
Andere fragten mich auch: "Wäre
es eine Option, zu ihm zu gehen,
statt sich bei dir zu treffen?"
Da fühle ich mich noch mehr
der Situation ausgeliefert.
Das ist vielleicht das falsche Wort.
Das klingt vielleicht hart.
Aber wenn bei mir etwas passiert,
was ich nicht will,
und die Person ein Nein
nicht akzeptiert, weiss ich:
Ich habe eine leere Weinflasche,
die ich als Kerzenständer nutze.
Im Notfall würde ich halt die nehmen.
Bei jemand anderem kann man
diese Szenarien nicht durchdenken.
Es ist schon krass.
Das ist auch das Problem
dieser Bewegung #NotAllMen.
Natürlich sind es nicht alle Männer.
Aber woher weiss ich das,
wenn ich ihn nicht kenne?
Ich war auch schon am Abend
mit einem Freund auf dem Heimweg,
weil es sicherer ist.
Es war aber erst sicher,
als unsere Wege sich trennten.
Weil er etwas von mir wollte
und übergriffig wurde.
Wir wissen halt nicht,
welche Männer.
Deshalb müssen wir
bei allen vorbereitet sein.
Selbst wenn man ein Taxi nimmt:
Wie oft wurde ich wohl schon
von Taxifahrern belästigt?
Und ich sehe ihm ja nicht an,
ob er so ist.
Das wäre schön,
dann wäre es einfacher.
Es ist leider niemandem
auf die Stirn geschrieben.
Deshalb
bin ich bei allen vorsichtig.
Ausser bei jenen,
die ich wirklich kenne.
Aber seit dem Vorfall
mit dem vermeintlichen Freund
wurde ich noch vorsichtiger.
V.a., wenn ich nicht nüchtern bin.
Hast du das Gefühl, es gibt Tipps?
Damit man sich sicherer fühlen kann
bei einem Date bei sich zu Hause?
Ich finde ehrlich gesagt,
dass das der falsche Ansatz ist.
Dann müssen wir uns wieder schützen.
Ich will z.B. auch
den Männern keine Tipps geben.
Mir ist wichtig:
Hört zu und urteilt nicht.
Schwierig finde ich
bei diesem ganzen Thema,
egal, ob ein Mann
oder eine Frau erzählt,
wenn man sagt: "Das ist doch nicht
so schlimm, du übertreibst."
Oder wenn man beim Thema
Vergewaltigung an Frauen sagt,
dass Männer
auch vergewaltigt werden.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Aber jetzt geht es um die Frauen.
Wenn sich jemand unsicher fühlt,
bringt es nichts zu sagen:
"Fühl dich nicht unsicher."
Denn man fühlt sich schon unsicher.
Das ist wie
einem weinenden Kind zu sagen:
"Du musst nicht weinen."
Das Kind weint schon. Es sagt nicht:
"Stimmt, jetzt höre ich gleich auf.
Danke für den Tipp!"
Das ist die Grundproblematik
in dieser Diskussion.
Wenn ich Frauen
etwas empfehlen kann:
Kommuniziert klar.
Wenn ihr euch unsicher fühlt, wenn
jemand zu euch kommt, schreibt ihm:
"Diesen Schritt mache ich sonst
nicht, ich fühle mich unsicher."
Es ist euer Recht,
ihr schuldet niemandem was.
Und wenn jemand
dann komisch reagiert,
dann soll man lieber auf ein Date
verzichten, als ein Risiko eingehen.
Ja, du hast recht.
Das ist ein guter Schluss, oder?